TURNED OUT TO BE TRUE, JAKE.
WELL TONIGHT, THERE IS EGG
ON A LOT OF FACES AFTER
ANOTHER STUNNING DONALD
TRUMP BREAK THROUGH.
LET'S DISCUSS THIS DRAMATIC
EVENT WITH FOX NEWS NATIONAL
SECURITY AND FOREIGN AFFAIRS
ANALYST WALID PHARES.
MICHAEL PILLS BURY OF THE
HUDSON INSTITUTE MIKE F.
>> KE CENTER FOR AMERICAN
PROGRESS.
MIKE, LET'S START WITH YOU.
I WAS CURIOUS TO SEE HOW THE
LEFT WAS GOING TO COVER THIS
TONIGHT BECAUSE THEY ARE ALL
ON STORMY DAMAGES.
ON THEIR USUAL POLICIES AND
STORIES OF RESISTANCE.
THIS REALLY IS SOMETHING.
LET'S SEE WITH A ULTIMATELY
HAPPENS.
"THE HUFFINGTON POST" HOME
PAGE HAS LIKE A MOCK TRUMP
AND MOCK KIM JONG UN FROM
THE OLYMPICS IMPERSONATORS.
THAT'S THE BEST THEY COULD
DO.
>> LOOK, THIS IS A BEST STEP
FORWARD.
THE DIPLOMACY THAT PRESIDENT
TRUMP HAS SIGNALED THE U.S.
IS WILLING TO DO WITH NORTH
KOREA IS THE RIGHT STEP.
THIS IS THE DIRECTION THAT
MANY PEOPLE HAVE BEEN
CALLING ON PRESIDENT TRUMP
TO TAKE FOR MORE THAN A YEAR
NOW.
I'M HAPPY TO SEE THAT HE HAS
DONE IT.
>> Laura: HE GOT THERE
BECAUSE HE TALKED TOUGH HE
DIDN'T GET THERE BECAUSE HE
PLAYED PATTY CAKE WITH KIM
JONG UN.
HE SAID YOU COME NEAR THIS
COUNTRY WITH A NUCLEAR
WEAPON WE WILL DESTROY YOU.
PEOPLE ON THE LEFT HOW HOW
DO YOU DO THIS.
NUCLEAR WAR.
WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
THEY WERE GOING CRAZY WITH
ONE TWEET ABOUT I HAVE A
NUCLEAR BUT THE
NUCLEAR BUTTOHE
NUCLEAR BUTTON.
THEY WENT NUTS ON THAT.
MICHAEL PILLS BURY, YOU HAVE
DECADES.
I KNOW YOU ARE VERY
SKEPTICAL.
BECAUSE LIKE ME HAVE YOU
SEEN NORTH KOREA PULL A FAST
ONE LIKE THIS BEFORE.
WHAT DO YOU THINK SO FAR?
>> WELL, IT'S TIME TO
CELEBRATE A GREAT VICTORY
WHEN IT HAPPENS.
YOU ARE QUITE RIGHT JUST IN
THE LAST TWO HOURS THE
MAINSTREAM LEFT WING MEDIA
HAS BEEN BESIDES THEMSELVES.
THIS REALLY CAN'T BE
HAPPENING OR THEY DON'T
REALLY KNOW HOW TO EXPLAIN
IT.
IT WASN'T PURCHASED.
THERE IS NO CONCESSIONS.
THE AMERICAN EXERCISES
CONTINUE FOR THE NEXT TWO
MONTHS.
THE ENTIRE SET OF
CONVENTIONAL ASSUMPTIONS
ABOUT NORTH KOREA HAS GONE
OUT THE WINDOW.
>> Laura: SERIES OF SOUND
BITES BY -- I LOVED CALLING
IT THE EXPERT.
THE EXPERT, THE EXPERT SAID.
THE EXPERT PREDICTED.
HEADLINES "U.S.A. TODAY"
ANALYSIS HOW TRUMP'S NUCLEAR
BUTTON TWEET COULD
JEOPARDIZE HIGHS FOREIGN
POLICY.
"NEWSWEEK" WILL TRUMP AND
KIM'S GAME OF NUCLEAR
CHICKEN BLOW UP THE WORLD?
NEW REPUBLIC THIS IS NOT A
NORTH KOREAN CRISIS IT'S A
TRUMP CRISIS.
WALID, TAKE IT AWAY.
>> THE CRITICS HAVE FOCUSED
ON THE PRESIDENT'S TWEETS.
WHAT THEY HAVE MISSED IS
EVERYTHING ELSE.
THEY DID NOT SEE THE TASK
FORCES SURROUNDING NORTH
KOREA.
DID NOT SEE PUTTING PRESSURE
ON CHINA MOBILIZING JAPAN
AND SOUTH KOREA.
THAT WE ARE WINNING THE GAME
AT THE UNITED NATIONS
COUNCIL WITH UNITED NATIONS
AND CHINA NOT RESOLUTION
AGAINST NORTH KOREA.
IT WAS WELL-CRAFTED THEY
MISSED A BIG GAME.
>> Laura: MICHAEL FUCHS DO
YOU BELIEVE THE PRESIDENT
WILL MEET WITH KIM JONG UN
NUT UNITED STATES OR SEOUL?
IF YOU HAD TO GET WHERE THEY
WILL BE MEETING.
THIS WILL BE WILD IF THIS
MEETING ACTUALLY ENDS UP
GOING FORWARD.
>> THAT IS THE BIG QUESTION
RIGHT NOW.
DOES THIS MEETING ACTUALLY
HAPPEN?
SOME SENIOR OFFICIALS FROM
THE WHITE HOUSE HAVE ALREADY
REFUSED TO STATE WHEN,
EXACTLY.
>> Laura: BEFORE MAY THEY
SAID.
>> PRESS SECRETARY SARAH
SANDERS DID NOT SAY.
SHE SAID TIME TO BE
DETERMINED.
SO I THINK THE BIG QUESTION
NOW IS WHAT IS THE PLAN?
WE HAVE RUSHED ON A COMPLETE
180 FROM TALK OF POTENTIAL
WAR AND MILITARY CONFLICT.
>> Laura: THAT WAS TO GET
THEM TO THE TABLE.
>> TO A SUMMIT MEETING.
SO I DO THINK THAT THE REAL
QUESTION NOW IS WHAT IS THE
NORTH KOREAN GAME HERE AND
WHAT STRATEGY DOSE THE
UNITED STATES HAVE TO
ACTUALLY EXTRACT REAL
CONCESSIONS FROM THE NORTH
KOREA?
>> Laura: I THINK WE HAVE
ALREADY EXTREACKETTED SOME
CONCESSIONS MICHAEL PILLS
BURRY.
MADELEINE ALBRIGHT CLANKING
CHAMPAGNE GLASSES WITH.
JOHN KERRY SHOWING
DIPLOMACY.
NOTHING CAME OF IT EXCEPT
NORTH KOREA GOT FARTHER AND
FARTHER ALONG WITH THIS
PROGRAM.
CHINA AND RUSSIA ACTING AS
PROXIES, SENDING TECHNOLOGY,
FOOD, SUPPLIES, FUEL.
MOST OF THAT NOT ALL OF THAT
WAS SHUT DOWN AND PRESIDENT
TRUMP PUSHED HARD AGAINST
THE CHINESE.
YOU WROTE THE BOOK ABOUT THE
HUNDRED YEAR MARATHON ABOUT
CHINA.
HOW DOES CHINA PLAY IN HERE?
>> I THINK THEY ARE EQUALLY
SURPRISED AS WE ARE THAT
ROCKET MAN, THAT'S HIS OLD
NAME, WE PROBABLY SHOULDN'T
USE THAT ANYMORE.
>> Laura: IS HE A BIG ELTON
JOHN FAN.
HE TOOK IT AS A COMPLIMENT
HE WAS CALLED ROCKET MAN.
>> CHINESE DIDN'T HELP MUCH
BUT THEY HELPED A LITTLE.
THEY WILL TRY TO TAKE CREDIT
AS MUCH AS THEY CAN.
I THINK THIS WHOLE PLAN
BEGAN DURING THE TRANSITION.
I THINK IT'S BEEN WELL
THOUGHT OUT.
PRESIDENT TRUMP, WHEN HE WAS
CAMPAIGNING DID NOT MAKE
NORTH KOREA HIS NUMBER ONE
ISSUE.
HE DID IT AFTER THE
TRANSITION.
AND I MUST SAY THAT
ACCORDING TO THE PRESS,
SECRETARY OF DEFENSE JIM
MATTIS CASS VERY
MATTIS WASS VERY
MATTIS WAS VVERY
MATTIS WAS VERRY
MATTIS WAS VERYY
MATTIS WAS VERY NERVOUS AND
CAUTIOUS.
>> Laura: DON'T WORRY.
I GOT IT THEY WERE VERY
NERVOUS ABOUT THIS WHOLE
THING.
WALID, THE PRESIDENT MADE IT
CLEAR TO HIS ADVISORS THAT
THE WAY WE HAD BEEN GOING
ABOUT THIS FOR DECADES
WASN'T WORKING.
AND HE MADE IT CLEAR TO
THEM, THEY ARE REPORTING
TONIGHT THAT WE WANTED A NEW
PATH FORWARD.
GIVE ME THE OPTIONS, HOW CAN